we turn now to a new book which warns
that voting an American democracy itself
may be in jeopardy it's called
what you need to know about voting and
why in it author Kim Whaley explains how
misinformation voter suppression foreign
interference and outdated technology
have influenced and even stopped people
from voting she's a law professor at the
university of baltimore good morning Kim
thanks for being with us you actually
say that the voting and American
democracy together could be in jeopardy
here
well we've seen many of the traditional
guardrails of democracy fall and when I
say that you know the Constitution is
like a job description or a contract
it's just a piece of paper if it's not
enforced in the breach that is if norms
or laws are broken if people in office
are doing things and there's no
consequences then the rules no longer
exist so at the end of the day with
really a dysfunctional Congress right
now that's so polarized voting is on the
ballot as really a check on the
existence of democracy itself people if
they go to the ballot box in November
need to take do so to take back their
democracy as government by we the people
or myself another constitutional
scholars worry that will slip into
something that's not democracy that
looks more like something approaching
authoritarianism and and we've seen
democracies fail even in our own
lifetime so this is not entirely a
hyperbole in this moment we're about to
vote in a presidential election in the
middle of a pandemic are we prepared for
it do you think well you know we have a
patchwork of 50 states and then sub
entities that manage voting so no we're
not prepared the states are flailing
financially there hasn't been the tax
revenue that's necessary and now states
are moving I think in a good way towards
mail and voting so people can vote
safely and don't have to choose between
their personal health or their right to
vote but that takes money that takes
coordination you have to order the
ballots in multiple languages
and people need to register now or
request their mail-in ballots now it's
kind of like RSVP'ing for a party so
that the states know you know how much
food to tell the caterer to order that's
really important and then of course
there will be that pulls open on that
day but there'll be fewer polls fewer
poll workers longer lines we saw it in
Georgia we saw problems in Wisconsin so
I think we have to expect that not every
vote is going to be timely counted what
we've had I mean you mentioned you
mentioned the long lines we had record
turnout in Georgia
I think in Iowa as well but at the same
time registration appears to be down in
in some places what what do you see
going on there well registration is down
it was up in January in February over
2016 but when kovat hit in March it
plummeted because under federal law you
register at the DMV and the DMV is
closed and you'd they're also obviously
election sites where you can register
officially Social Services agencies and
also a huge get-out-the-vote efforts for
registration at large public gatherings
none of that is happening what we saw in
Wisconsin as I indicated as people
really do want to vote but when they
sign up late later closer to the
election date but there was a tsunami of
applications and just not the resources
to catch up so again earlier is better
and as I read recently in a piece in the
bulwark apathy and cynicism around
voting is one of the biggest objections
to voting and so I encourage people to
grab a friend or to who's not used to
voting and get them out because there's
really nothing more important in this
moment whatever your issue is that you
care about immigration reform climate
change it all hinges on a functioning
democracy all right the book is what you
need to know about voting and why Kim
Whaley thank you so much for being with
us